you know the i don't actually i'm not
like that invested in chores like in the
arguments with it and whatever what if
you like chores whatever i don't give a
[ __ ] the only thing that pisses me off
is these people who act like not using a
dishwasher and cleaning the plates makes
you some kind of like god-tier chad like
have you seen this online no people who
are like bro i use a dishwasher cringe
dude clean it by hand it gets it out
better or like parents and stuff you're
like using the dishwasher really it's
like what do what do you mean like
that's just literally what the
dishwasher was involved yeah the
dishwasher the dishwasher makes so much
sense and it uses like one tenth the
amount of [ __ ] water why are you
still pretending like like getting in
there and and wasting time wasting all
this [ __ ] water makes you some kind
of [ __ ] god-tier chat or something
but like no one says the same argument
about like cars right no no it's like
bro you're driving like crazy like
laundry right
no nobody's like bro you don't wash your
lawn you'll close my hand bro get the
[ __ ] out of here dude just doesn't do it
right just didn't do it the same way
it's like bro what the [ __ ]
my hand really gets the [ __ ] [ __ ] out
of it yeah i mean i get it back in the
day bro like dishwashers they they take
a lot of energy man and when when you're
trying to save costs and energy bills
you better be washing it by hand yeah
but you don't do that you're wasting it
on water you're wasting it on water i
believe like
i don't know if this is just like my mom
and dad this is this wash me but i
apparently is more cost effective to
wash my hands if not why wouldn't why
would everyone not get a dishwasher then
what because the dishwasher machine
itself is quite expensive but if you
have it
not using it not every kitchen has
enough space for a dishwasher well yeah
true it's like a really small dish like
i'm pretty sure if you own a dishwasher
there's no benefit except like maybe
you've like a giant pot that cannot be
cleaned in the dishwasher yeah that
makes sense there's an argument for that
but like acting like you it can't clean
your plate right are you kidding me like
[ __ ] off that's literally what it was
invented for a clean plate to argue with
the best out of any other type of thing
that you put in the dishwasher i don't
know people people get so [ __ ] i see
so many people online being like yeah
man just dishwasher man she doesn't do
it for me what do you mean what do you
mean doesn't door for you get another
dishwasher i don't know like maybe they
just enjoy doing the dishes i can
understand if you can't afford a
dishwasher or it's too much or it
doesn't fit like that those are all
valid reasons to not do it but when you
own one and you're like no no no no
to me to me dishwashers has always been
the machine that separates i guess the
more well-off to the people
who um
how can i word this
the dishwasher has always been like the
big separator between let's say the
middle class and the working class can i
say that in which countries globally or
globally or i don't know it's always
been like in like that in my mind but
because like i mean definitely in japan
i would say yeah because i don't know
like for some reason everyone owns like
a washing machine right everyone owns a
washing machine you know that's that's
just standard but for some reason in my
mind whenever i went to a house and they
had a dishwasher i was like oh in the uk
yeah well in the uk i never i've never
had a dishwasher in the uk i don't know
really i don't know maybe this is my
privilege
i don't think i ever went to anyone's
house who didn't have a dish yeah so
really yeah in australia i think
everyone has okay am i the weird one
maybe because i'm in the countryside and
there's just way more room like the
houses were definitely way bigger i
definitely feel that way in japan right
because it's like until i went to my
friend's place and they had a dishwasher
i just thought the concept of
dishwashers didn't exist in japan yeah
because every other house i was just
like oh there's the kitchen is so small
there is physically not yet
your kitchen your house was really
[ __ ] small yeah yeah yeah so that
makes sense why you wouldn't have one
but like even
even going around friends places and
even going around families places nobody
it was rare for anyone i know to have a
dishwasher
i wonder why because i'm pretty sure the
people in brighton generally make more
money than where i was from but i think
maybe what you get for the houses like
every kitchen i i'd ever seen was like
decently sized it was like america-sized
but that's because all the houses were
[ __ ] i don't know in in america
pretty much every house i've been to
yeah
maybe it's just like kitchen size and
yeah okay well we have tons of room
because dishwashers that themselves
aren't as expensive like aren't that
expensive like compared to like uh but i
guess it's not as mandatory as like a
fridge and other [ __ ] yeah um i don't
know yeah dishwasher is when like you
you're you're privileged enough to be
able to pay someone to wash your dishes
for you you know whereas clothes washing
clothing that's that's that's a
necessity you know no one wants to wash
their clothes by hand that's weird isn't
it could you look up the savings uh what
how much dishwashers help or something
i'm pretty sure you because i you know
like the eco mode on dishwashers yeah
i'm pretty sure they can
like they can use an absurd amount of
like um
like a crazy little amount of water to
clean your dishes like a really really
really small amount yeah like and it's
like amazing but no one ever does eco
because everyone thinks eco [ __ ] that i
do
do you yeah you're the only person i
know has ever done yeah i'm like i'm
like full blast on that why would you
not use eco it's
why wouldn't you
i didn't even know that wasn't like i
thought it would i don't want my dishes
to be less clean that's what i thought
what are you talking about it cleans
your dishes it's all the same okay
listen if i have an appliance right i
have some advice maybe wash it by hand
because on the machine i'm like it's
like do you want it to clean hard
medium or slowly and i'm like hard
hard yeah
yeah i got a full blast on that [ __ ] i
want that [ __ ] to be clean no difference
in not bringing man i'm like yo i gotta
save every ounce
some things are just ingrained in my
mind okay is that oh so wait where did
you learn to use eco then
so you said that you was ingrained in
your mind where where are they getting
great um uh restaurant so the only
dishwasher i've ever had is in the
restaurant because restaurants because
that makes sense yeah we needed to own
we need to own one so obviously you got
to go eco oh yeah yeah yeah
this is the first time no i had a
dishwasher in my place in london it was
same kind of deal
but yeah no i that one didn't have eco
this one the one i have now does i think
i don't know it's all in kanji i don't
even think my one has eco right yeah i
just press start i don't
i
because i
it's i open it up there's like eight
little eight different kanjis and i'm
like well i know when i press start and
go yeah it cleans it so i'm just not
gonna i just yeah i just go strong and
then start yeah see that's me in washing
machines even if it's in english all
right i look at all that we have some
information sorry yeah so if you have a
full load it is more efficient and uh
cost more cost efficient and energy
efficient
but only if you
because then i pull it out and half the
[ __ ] isn't [ __ ] clean because i like
quadruple stuff oh cause it's like way
too close to each other yeah yeah yeah
how big is your dishwasher tiny oh okay
it's a tiny japanese one's a tiny i have
i have one that comes out of my thing
and it's maybe like a because the you
the us the one i have we had in the uk
was [ __ ] stupid
it's probably normal u.s size massive i
think it's like a half or a third
i think it's like about that big yeah
maybe maybe it's a half or a third yeah
not that deep so yeah if you have a meal
you know like let's say you i don't know
you've had like lunch and dinner yeah
four plates a bunch of side maybe you
had soup with it the glasses like
that'll fill up yeah because i've run
out of plates and cutlery between just
the two of us before the dishwasher
becomes full why does social can only
hold like
uh like five plates oh okay and then it
can hold some glasses and then maybe a
few other little things it's not it's
not a long yeah my dishwasher is massive
yeah you've got an american sized one
yeah yeah yeah yeah i think that's
because i think i prefer having my size
though no i do i would as well because
that would the dishwasher i have right
now because it's built into my house
it's way too big for just two people
okay right the only time i actually feel
we get
like
value out of it is when we have like a
party or have
after a few days it's pretty full and
yeah easy i like it because i hated
doing dishes in my old place in japan
[ __ ] hated it sucks no i i mean i
hate doing chores i always hate to do
you you like leave them in a dry for a
little while and then like the water
didn't dry properly and it stains the
glass it looks disgusting and it looks
like someone sneezed in your glass and
you're like i like the residue
i should have dried it but i don't use a
towel because sometimes the towel leaves
like stains you know not stains but like
it like the marks yeah yeah
this washer is great yeah that's that's
why you got to like hand dry your
glasses if you don't want the stains no
i did i used to but then you maybe the
towel would like streak it or something
and then you're like i'm going to kill
myself some advice use your hands
right in there no that's what that
problem was when i was using my hands
okay
you're monkey handsome enough of my
privilege for now for this part